[Musique]
xi a toujours était peut-être le plus
grand cellier du monde sa vocation a été
de recevoir tous les vins produits dans
toutes les régions de la france et
malgré toutes les calomnies dont il a
été l'objet en 50 ans c'est le lieu de
france où il ya eu le moins de
procédures étaient
[Musique]
près de la scène il existe pour combien
de temps encore ce que l'on appelait la
ville en prison le cellier du monde
c'est bercy avec ses 240 de négociants
et ses 4 millions d'hectolitres de
production annuelle c'est en 1804 que
bercy qui n'était alors qu'un immense
parc se transforme en un lieu où le
commerce du vin apparaît très rapidement
les négociants arrive merci devenait le
plus vaste marché européen google
c'est l'annexion
1876 bercy était clôturée devenait la
ville en prison et bercy se développe
par la scène par le train par la route
le vin arrivent de partout il y avait
alors près de 600 magasins et 60 cave
affecté au stockage du 1910 images
typiques c'est la grande inondation
bercy est transformée en cité lacustre
les fûts flotte on navigue en bateau
dans les rues et puis pour qui a connu
des rssi c'était village avec ses
habitudes ses traditions son esprit et
dans quelques mois ou quelques années le
village du vin va disparaître seuls les
arbres resteront peut-être pour
témoigner et raconter mais nous n'en
sommes pas encore là et revenons
quelques années en arrière 54 ans
exactement à l'époque où monsieur boutet
arrivait à bercy quand je suis arrivé
ici après la guerre de 14-18 c'est à
dire le 1er janvier 10 221 on va
l'entreprise bercy était encore à cette
époque en bas
généralement
occupés à 80% par des négociants dans la
pièce sur elle et distribution du vin
dans la région parisienne uniquement aux
fûts de différentes contenances dave
1925 et a commencé à paraître la mise en
bouteille un vin qui s'est développée
progressivement et qui peu à peu a
remplacé la distribution du vin en
assurant la livraison directe au
consommateur de vin miss en bouteille
directement dans les entrepôts et
combien de temps que vous êtes à bercy
consacré 22 ans
vous souvenez comment ça va se passer il
ya vingt deux ans que ça a beaucoup
changé énormément énormément nous
l'avions les bouteilles non pas avec une
machine comme celle ci met à tourillon
après ça ou alors ont renversé les
livres de suez il fallait remettre aussi
vit dans des caisses puis ensuite les
envoyer vers la machine de tirage on
faisait aussi beaucoup de tirage à la
main
[Musique]
puisque le visage de bercy était
différent aussi oui tout à fait
c'était en tous points de vue au point
de vue de l'ambiance
maintenant bien entendu c'est du
personnel
comment dire est plus courant alors
qu'avant c'était vraiment il fallait
uniquement des personnes de métier la
banque j'ai beaucoup plus de plus tard à
gossi maintenance unique molvaer à
l'époque c'était beaucoup beaucoup de
suite l'impression qu'ils aient une
contradiction dans tout ce que l'on
entend dans bercy vous voulez rester à
bercy mais pourtant si on se promène on
a l'impression que les bâtiments sont
assez vétustes et d'autre part on entend
toujours dire merci ce n'est plus ce que
c'était ce n'est plus la grande époque
alors est évident c'est plus de la
grande époque mais vous savez de métier
de marchand de vin à subissent de celui
tous les métiers il ya une dégradation
dans chaque métier mais ce que nous
regrettons surtout à bercy n'ont pas
seulement à bercy mais c'est ce qui se
passe donc tous les négociants de france
c'est l'esprit l'esprit marchand de vin
et chaabi marchand de vin avec un m
majuscule et 20 également parce que
voyez vous il y avait un esprit d équipe
dans le temps le négociant le maître de
chai les livreurs les chauffeurs tout le
monde refaisant une équipe et je me
rappelle bien moi le matin quand les
camions étaient chargés et bien il y
avait cet esprit qui étaient autour d'un
tonneau sur lequel on avait mis soit une
entreprise soit des rillettes 1 et puis
on buvait la bonne bouteille de vin que
cette fois du beaujolais ou un autre
petit bordeaux un petit bourgogne et sas
a resserré les liens d'amitiés sincères
du bien de toute l'équipe de la maison
[Musique]
et
si l'on
regarde tout
ce que bercy a eu comme je disais ses
heures de gloire mais qu'avec
l'évolution des transports la mise en
bouteille à la propriété si vous voulez
sa raison d'être s'est amenuisé de plus
en plus c'est tout ce que j'ai voulu
dire si vous voulez je pense qu'il est
aussi simple maintenant la plupart des
commerçants est infini à des chaînes
d'achat ou étant affiliés un circuit de
distribution de stocker des vins déjà
prêts à la vente qui sont et amy prêts à
la vente sur le lieu de production donc
en bouteille et en carton en général il
est plus simple de les partager ensuite
dans les duels diverses succursales que
de faire venir ses vins en vrac à paris
puis de les mettre dans des cartons et
ensuite les distribuer oui parfois pour
vous était bien commode tout de même
d'aller à bercy et de prendre tout votre
vin et tous les 20 là vous êtes obligés
de faire des commandes à droite et à
gauche
certains états à bercy on avait la
possibilité de trouver c'est surtout les
vins en un même lieu seulement
l'inconvénient aussi qu'il y avait six
voulais c'était
la difficulté
d'accès dès maintenant dans bercy si
vous voulez bercy c'est quand même bien
que ce soit au centre de paris si elle
était camions les terrasses étaient pas
très commode et je pense que toutes les
façons ce genre de commerce n'est pas
supprimée si on aura des remplaçants en
périphérie peut-être plus plus dispersée
mais des remplaçants périphérie
certainement est ce qu ils s'appelleront
négociant c'est pas certain
on pourra voir par exemple des entrepôts
simplement qui ce qui appartiendront à
des négoces bordelais ou à des groupes
de producteurs
bordelais ou d'autres régions de france
quel pourcentage actuellement des vins
vous achetez à bercy pour l'instant
c'est fini je crois que dans le vin
qui est un produit traditionnel qui
existe depuis des siècles c'est un
produit qui a souvent été attaqués que
souvent attaqués mais en fait il est
passé et bien passer à travers les âges
et donc l'idée c'est un progrès qui n'a
pas que des inconvénients
eh bien je crois que la tradition est
disons la façon de soigner le vin
que nous te connaissais les précédentes
générations étaient excellentes
les moyens modernes et en particulier de
la modernisation des commerces et de la
distribution nous a sans doute obliger à
nous adapter mieux et à avoir des
installations industrielles mais
effectivement c'est pas forcément un
bien pour le vin et donc je crois que
bercy représente en fait bien que bercy
et étaient souvent attaqué une certaine
garantie pour le produit lui même
[Musique]
mais voilà ça fait 50 ans de métier
voilà
un métier comme un autre
bal
pour le faire
il ne reste plus qu'un seul y est averti
mais il existe d'autres métiers
spécifiques du vin un exemple le maître
de chai ça consiste au traitement des
vins les bains arrive par citerne aux
entrepôts sont mis dans des cuves en
principe vers et la nouvelle et sont
reposés quelques temps et ensuite
nous apportons quelques traitements
qui sont nécessaires bien entendu étant
donné que les vins travail
transport et
ensuite lui veut effectivement poutrage
nous changeons donc d'aucune nous
compterons revêtons entre tulle et à
partir de là nous en voyons sur la
machine de tirage alors vous votre
confiance est justement de surveiller un
petit peu tout les rations de surveiller
le traitement et l'évolution des vins
pour apprendre ce métier il faut avoir
un palais excellence avoir goûté le vin
ou se sont détruits oui ben oui quoi
belle en principe
c'est presque à dos
beaucoup de personnes il faut faut
savoir goûter pour quand on goûte à
vendre quelquefois il va suivre une
évolution
il faut reconnaître il faut les suivre
alors vous pensez avoir un palais
parfait vous savez reconnaître oui oui
sans
ce mode ici
j'ai un palet est excellent
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
et
je pense que percy dans l'esprit des
gens sur les
sur tous les gens qui donc ont connu
bien si après guerre civile et c'était
le vin ordinaire parce que si on
achetait des valeurs enfin dans le midi
de la france
je pense qu'ils étaient de qualité
inférieure à ce qu'on trouve maintenant
notamment dans les corbières ou dans le
minervois et au point de vue degrés il
était nécessaire il ya encore une
quinzaine d'année d'acheter des vannes
algérie à fort degré pour les assemblées
à liévin du miti de très faible degré
pour arriver à donner aux gens des vins
de table disons obtenant au moins on se
devrait tandis que maintenant dans le
midi de la france on arrive par une
sélection de ses pages et par d'autres
procédés à obtenir des vins qui sont
parfaitement consommable notamment sous
l'appellation de l'inde pays directement
pris 100 ha de grès quelques froid
toujours constant l'appellation vin de
pays permettant de commercialiser des
vins avec des variations de quelques
dixièmes je pense que vers 6,6 voulait
avait sa raison d'être au début du
siècle quand les transports et wake
était lent quand la propriété était mal
équipé pour embouteiller quand les
petits marchands de valence hui si vous
voulez
n'avait pas la possibilité d'avoir des
courtiers qui achète directement la
propriété je pense que toutes les façons
si on arrête une profession aussi plus
ou moins bercy attend l'expropriation
c'est que bercy n'a plus sa raison
d'être vous aurez en vin ordinaire je
pense deux ou trois gros embouteilleurs
qui se réinstallent la région parisienne
en périphérie à londres où les gros
camions ou le chemin de fer est
accessible mais pour ce qui est des vins
fins etc je pense que l'avenir et la
mise en bouteilles
[Musique]
les détaillants qui soit restaurateurs
qui soit cafetiers qui soit et chansons
france ont intérêt à ce que bercy tienne
parce que à bercy on soit en grosse
quantité et quand on dit grosse quantité
on dit prix de revient de plus bas
surtout en matière de transport alors il
est très facile par exemple aujourd'hui
cette déblocage du beaujolais nouveau
est bien dans les 48 heures tous les
cafetiers de paris et restaurateurs vont
être fournies en primeurs alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent chercher la
propriété eh bien ça serait que dans
deux ou trois jours qui sera livré et ça
serait un minimum alors c'est un
avantage c'est un avantage aussi pour le
camionneur car nous avons énormément de
camionneurs qui travaillent sur le
persil et chaud pas que bercy a sa place
comme il ya des entrepôts pour leur
place dans les grandes villes de france
à soit lille strasbourg brest le mans ou
lyon
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai entendu dire sais pas si c'est vrai
que certains négociants ici dans bercy
ne mettait pas leur adresse de bercy
parce que ça ne se vendait pas su pas
tout à fait vrai mais tout de même
disons qu'elles soient ces combos bien
sûr à 75% le consommateur préfère avoir
sur l'étiquette le nom d'un propriétaire
ou le nom éventuellement d'un négociant
éleveur des places de production mais
vous savez il ya quand même une bonne
réputation à bercy avec des
propriétaires qui sont également
négociants et des négociants qui livrent
leurs clients d'une façon tout à fait
bien et normal et on a des vins à bercy
qui valse de la propriété puisque nous
sommes légalement pour les élever
[Musique]
notre position est celle d'un autre si
vous voulez des négociants en vins assez
importants ont la région parisienne pour
bercy qui livrent différents types de
clientèle si bien les épiciers que le
supermarché et que les cafés restaurants
je crois que nous intégrons assez bien
parce que effectivement l'entreprise à
l'origine
et a été implanté depuis très longtemps
dans bercy et donc c'est elle a grandi
avec dans bercy et je pense donc qu'il
n'ya aucun problème en ce qui concerne
son intégration dans l'ambiance de bercy
[Musique]
effectivement il se dégage de bercy où
certains nombres
une certaine ambiance un peu fort le
folklorique traditionnelle égal surtout
un certain esprit de tradition qui sied
bien aux vins et qui peut-être ne se
retrouvera pas de la même façon dans des
installations modernes que l'on peut
réaliser ailleurs
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui a heureusement concernés mais à
cette époque vous ne voyez pas dans les
rues mais camions citernes
le wagon réservoir à cette époque là
était un wagon réservé à on voit mono
foudre ou qui foulent de contenance de
50 % inférieur à ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui et la totalité du camionnage
à ce moment là en dise le 120 ou tout au
moins à
90 % et est assurée uniquement par la
traction hippomobile donc les vins
arrivait déjà l'entreprise par
l'intermédiaire des référés la sncf leur
est arrivé par la voie fluviale les
manipulations était fait évidemment à ce
moment là dans à l'aide de deux minuit
qui contenait six eto'o et qui était
évidemment traîner encore par des
chevaux et avec le vieux un vieux
matériel qui a complètement disparu mais
que certains bronzage concerne conserve
encore très vivante souvenir le hacker
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
temps
[Musique]
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai on se connaît
tous
- bien sûr depuis qu'il ya eu à louvain
qui a disparu et il est venu beaucoup de
d'autres négociants mais c'est quand
même rester un village
avec ma vie du village vous pouvez me
raconter un peu comment elle s est vite
bon maintenant
- bien sûr si on parlait de l'époque
alors parlez moi de l'époque il y avait
on faisait l'entrecôte bercy
avec des vieux fûts
qui était trempée dans la nuit avant de
manière à ce que la brise est vraiment
le goût de le goût de bain et alors à
cette époque là il y avait le marchand
moutarde et même de cornichons qui
passait de chez hanche et bien sûr son
époque
il y alors tout village son église il ya
une église à bercy il ya une église oui
l'église de bercy là sa chambre dit là
où l époque aussi il y avait une journée
de congé une journée persie à la
saint-vincent s'amassant seul patron dé
tous les vignerons au patron des
vignerons
[Musique]
en
en 1
[Musique]
[Rires]
est-ce que vous pensez que justement
cette ambiance de village vous allez
pouvoir marc rey et ailleurs non non
parce que en principe beaucoup de
négociants sont des six mines et
maintenant les uns sont bons dans une
région les autres dans une autre autour
de paris on ne pourra plus recréer cette
ambiance on vous avez petit gagné au
modernisme et laurent il perdre en opère
vian son père aux ennuis oui c'est très
ennuyeux parce qu'on était habitué à
cette ambiance
qui était vraiment le vin
[Musique]
effectivement la disparition des
entrepôts de bercy posera des problèmes
mais le principal problème est celui de
l'incertitude dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons puisque cette disparition a été
programmée et annoncée de nombreuses
années et qu en fait elle est toujours
en devenir puisque les différents
projets quand et élaborer jusque là
semble aujourd'hui un peu en bas le
conseil municipal des 70 et par une
décision de 71 a décidé de ne pas
reconstruire notre peau de bercy
de ce fait quand nous serons obligés de
quitter bercy et quand les négociations
avec la ville de paris où ses
mandataires aurons nous auront amené à
choisir des solutions nous serons appelé
les uns et les autres ont raison des
impératifs de notre profession qui
nécessite une grande surface au sol et
qui ne permet pas en raison de sa faible
rentabilité de payer des loyers très
élevés nous serons obligés de nous
répartir dans la région parisienne comme
du reste un certain nombre de maisons
l'an déjà prévus alors donc bercy va
éclater ce qu'est réellement franchement
ça va gêner votre profession oui ça va
lâcher n'est pas ce qu'il ya un problème
de transport qui va être énorme
celui qui va s'installer dans le parmi
nos amis négociant à 10 15 20 km à l'est
20 km se font leur entrée dans le centre
de paris ça va faire une demi journée
pour le transporter et de camionneurs
n'aura rien pu livrer dans sa matinée
parce qu'il commencera à arriver sur
paris et dans les frais généraux vont
augmenter forcément les frais généraux
augmente le prix du vin ça pour la
marchandise qui augmentera mais les
frais généraux tout autour et puis
no evil ou d'une chose c'est que bercy
amène des impôts or si chaque négocions
de bercy 120 en banlieue grande banlieue
c'est paris qui touchera les impôts ça
sera des villes des environs de la
capitale
alors là aussi il fallait y penser et
puis je crois que il raffole chacun y
met du sien on verra bien par la suite
mais enfin on sera tous obligés de
s'exprimer si j'ose dire de notre
territoire
depuis près de deux siècles que nous
sommes là et bien c'est bien dommage
parce qu'il y avait des traditions qui
était entré dans nos moeurs il y avait
des belles choses qui se faisait et si
ça ça disparaît ça sera une image de
paris qui disparaîtra également
[Musique]